Film Courage: What’s the formula for writing
a great story?
Dr. Ken Atchity, Author/Producer: I think
that a great story starts with finding a character
in a strange situation and working that character
out of that situation.
Faulkner said that that’s the way his novel
started is that a character haunted him and
he allowed it to haunt him until questions
started coming and he gave the example of
a novel I wrote once started with a girl sitting
in a tree with muddy pants and her knees were
bruised and she’s looking in the window
of the house from the tree and she’s crying.
And so I started asking questions about why
were her knees bruised, why were her knees
not bruised and it’s because she climbed
this tree since she was little and didn’t
have any problem climbing the tree.
Why were her pants dirty?
Well because her brother pushed her in the
creek and that’s why she ran home and why
was she looking in the window?
Because she was told not to come in the house.
What was she looking at in the window?
Well it was the funeral of her grandfather
and so on.
And when he had all of those questions he
could then answer those questions.
The think about Faulkner that kind of illustrates
my view of creativity is he didn’t write
this down.
You know I always say if you trust your mind,
the story will form itself in your mind.
The minute you start writing it down, you
are interfering with your mind because you
are now dealing with pieces of paper and we
start feeling possessive about pieces of paper
and we want to do something with them.
We want to put them in order but what if one
of these pieces of paper isn’t a good one
at all?
Well he will forget that.
He will forget the thing about her knees.
For example if that’s not a good one.
But he leaves it all in his mind because that
way it’s free to form (almost like an embryo)
any way it wants to form.
And once it’s fully formed then you sit
down and write it out.
I always said people will never have writer’s
block at all if they simply never sit down
to write until they know what they are going
to write when they sit down.
And if you know that in advance then you just
start dashing it out.
That’s why you limit your time 45 minutes
to an hour and at the end of it you can’t
wait to write more.
Perfect go to tomorrow and do it then because
that energy will be there already whereas
if you sort of run out of things to write
you’ve misused your time management.
So I think that’s how a story starts is
by some character that haunts you until you
have to write about it and then you go an
apply all the other rules about storytelling
on top of that but basically it starts with
the character and no matter how great a writer
you are if you don’t have an intriguing
character at the heart of it doesn’t matter
because you’re not going to hold your reader.
You’re not going to hold your audience.
The audience just wants to see people.